you
since the beginning of mankind as a
species weapons have been some of our
cleverest and most important inventions
over hundreds and thousands of years of
war and killing humanity has continued
to devise new ways to kill one another
often in brutal fashion from the club to
the spear to the bow the catapult the
musket up till today with those nukes we
looked at in the last video they all
serve the same purpose but over the
course of several international
conventions some of these weapons have
been banned from warfare for being too
inhumane if the sole purpose of these
devices is to kill the enemy what makes
one method more inhumane than another
let's say you and I are on different
sides of a military conflict in the
mid-1600s
we're taking shots at each other with
our horribly inaccurate rifles until
finally you get a hit luckily for me
your bullet just grazed me somewhat less
luckily I die from infection a few days
later why because it's the 1600s and
you'd like to store your bullets and
corpses or latrine bits to make sure
that if you do manage to hit somebody
they die from infection this storing of
bullets and poisonous or infectious
substances was the catalyst for the
strasbourg agreement of 1675 the first
ever international agreement banning the
use of chemical weapons the general
sentiment was that using such an
indirect and unpleasant means to kill
the enemy was not befitting the
principles of civilized warfare let's
fast-forward to the 22nd of April 1915
the Second Battle of Ypres in Belgium
during World War one saw the first
successful mass use of poison gas in war
the German army released 171 tons of
chlorine gas over a stretch of about six
and a half kilometers chlorine gas is a
really nasty substance it irritates the
eyes and skin and when inhaled it reacts
violently with the human body causing
the lungs to fill with fluid those
unlucky enough to be caught in the gas
cloud often drowned painfully from the
fluid inside their own lungs as chlorine
gas was a rather new development and
weaponry the methods the Germans used to
deploy it were quite crude the chlorine
was stored in nearly 6,000 cylinders
weighing 41 kilograms each which the
Germans carried by hand to the
frontlines the canisters were opened by
hand as soon as the wind shifted towards
the French releasing a sweeping plume of
noxious gas the Germans themselves
suffered many injuries and deaths from
their own gas as it was impossible to
control once out of the canisters when
the chlorine reached the French lines
within 10 minutes 6,000 had died of
asphyxiation and tissue damage to the
lungs
since chlorine gas is denser than air it
quickly flowed down into the trenches
causing the French troops to scramble
over the top to escape right into German
gunfire chlorine gas and several other
poisonous chemicals continue to see use
throughout the rest of the war accounted
for 1.3 million casualties and were the
driving factor behind the well-known
Geneva Protocol of 1925 it's full title
was the protocol for the prohibition of
the use and war of asphyxiating
poisonous or other gases and of
bacteriological methods of warfare
doesn't exactly roll off the tongue in
essence the Geneva Protocol is a treaty
that bans the use of chemical and
biological weapons in international
armed conflicts like the Strasbourg
agreements the thinking behind the
Geneva Protocol was that chemical
weapons caused unnecessary pain and
suffering in its victims as well as
significant mental and emotional trauma
several years later world war two came
along and with it a new batch of devious
weapons the Japanese employed horrible
booby traps to defend their homeland the
most famous being the hidden spike pits
soldiers would step on a thin layer of
foliage and tumble down into rows of
sharpened bamboo spikes to make matters
worse the Japanese often coated the
spikes in human or animal species which
led to terrible infections among the
injured these traps killed and maimed
thousands of troops over the course of
the war the Americans had their own new
toys as well namely the two atomic bombs
that decimated Hiroshima and Nagasaki
world war ii also saw the devastating
use of napalm napalm was the ideal
incendiary weapon because it was
incredibly simple and cheap to produce
it was stable and it stuck to whatever
it hit all those features made napalm
very popular and it accounted for more
dead japanese soldiers and civilians
than the two atomic bombs once the dust
of the Second World War settled America
enjoyed relative peace until the
disastrous Vietnam War with the jungle
terrain came new means of killing what
better way to clear foliage and flush
out the enemy than by using fire the
flamethrower
used extensively in both world wars
proved itself particularly useful in
torching entire villages and hideouts
napalm bombs also saw extensive use with
the u.s. reportedly dropping about 388
thousand tons of it over the course of
the war compared to sixteen thousand
five hundred tons in World War two the
Vietnam War was hugely unpopular among
the American public for many reasons
among those were concerned that these
fire weapons were cruel and inhumane
sure enough on October 10th 1980 the
United Nations Convention on certain
conventional weapons came to a close and
with it came new legislation that
pivoted the use of many different types
of weapons incendiary devices are listed
under what's referred to as protocol 3
which restricts their use in any
situation in which civilians are present
interestingly napalm is an entirely
banned it can be used to set fire to
forested areas that conceal enemy troops
or vehicles but it's strictly prohibited
in civilian inhabited areas other
weapons banned by the C CCW include any
form of gas including tear gas which can
still be used in domestic riot
oddly enough spike pits undetectable
fragment weapons
meaning any weapon with the primary
effect of leaving shrapnel in the human
body that is undetectable by x-ray also
included are non self-destructing and
non self deactivating mines outside
fenced monitored and marked areas these
mines must also be removed when the
conflict is resolved and finally perhaps
more relevant to today's battlefield
blinding laser weapons any weapon with
the ability to cause permanent blindness
or severe irreversible eye damage is
strictly prohibited so what do we make
of all this
even though we have a long list of
prohibited weapons what's the common
thread what exactly makes them more
inhumane than a bayonet or a 50 caliber
machine gun as you may have guessed the
main concern is not for the combatants
but for civilian populations the
protocols are very firm on the position
that indiscriminate weapons weapons that
cannot be used to target only hostile
troops must never be used that includes
cluster bombs that can blanket a wide
area large explosives like nuclear bombs
and hidden weapons such as mines and
booby traps of course a secondary
concern for the C CCW was indeed the
humanity of the combatants deaths at the
hands of another is certainly a tragic
fate but at least Nations have been able
to come together and recognize that no
one deserves to suffer unnecessarily the
future of war is bound to be interesting
with later restrictions and
technological advances maybe we'll even
see a complete ban on human involvement
in war computers and drones of all sorts
stand poised to change the battlefield
forever we'll just have to wait and see
how long it takes that future to arrive
as always this video was intended to
spark your curiosity in the subject if
you'd like to learn more about banned or
inhumane weapons check out the links in
the description if you enjoyed this
video please take a moment to subscribe
to my channel to help me keep posting
two videos a week feel free to leave a
like or a dislike as you please and tell
me what you think about banned weapons
and warfare in general in the comments
you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or binge watching them all
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see
in the next video
[Music]